abdul j'irai s'est installé en 2005 sur
ses terres en campagne du cosec
autrefois ces 20 hectares et est
entièrement plantée en banane et lorsque
le problème du chlordécone a été
soulevée les premières analyses du sol
et des légumes plantés ici se sont
révélées catastrophiques notamment ceux
qu'on appelle la cucurbitacée c'est à
dire le concombre le giraumon la
courgette tout ça oui parce que ça me
gonfle madoff lui à des taux jeudi les
effroyables
heureusement l'agriculteur s'était
diversifié en arboriculture avec de
nombreux fruits locaux ou exotiques
le chlordécone n'émigrent pas dans les
fruits et l'exploitant s'est recentré
totalement sur cette production
fruitière par déontologie explique-t-il
je me dis que l'agriculteur il est là
pour nourrir les gens et en fait et
quand vous nourrissez quelqu'un vous lui
donnez en fait la vie vous n'êtes pas là
pour lui ôter la vie en lui donnant de
produits empoisonnés dans quelques
semaines ses fruits porteront le label 0
chlordécone la démarche initiée par le
parc naturel a déjà rallié une
cinquantaine d'agriculteurs leurs
produits soumis à analyse est certifié 0
chlordécone seront bientôt
reconnaissable il y aura la belle qui
sera apposée sur chaque fruit ce qui
permettra au milieu avec un code-barres
d'identifier l'origine la parcelle est
le propriétaire
pour des raisons de santé publique nous
ne pouvons plus jouer le jeu comme ça
s'est passé auparavant
il faut absolument que l'ensemble des
professionnels puissent avoir conscience
de leurs responsabilités
les aliments qui sont mis sur le marché
ne doivent avoir zéro chlordécone la
limite maximale résiduelles les lmr nous
ne voulons pas qu'il y ait une lmr pour
un produit considéré comme la communauté
scientifique comme étant un poison
le parc naturel propose un
accompagnement technique aux
agriculteurs qui s'inscrivent dans la
démarche que leurs terres soient
fortement contaminée ou pour un doux le
label permettra de rassurer un
consommateur peut être tenté de ne plus
acheter local
le label est une très bonne chose
pourquoi parce que tout simplement ça va
assurer une traçabilité des produits
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous savons que bon
tout le monde nous observe
pour savoir si les produits ne vont pas
venir d'ailleurs nous nous concurrencer
et se baser sur tout sur cette publicité
qui peut être négative et l'espoir est
permis en martinique où 60 % de la
surface agricole utile ne serait pas du
tout contaminée par le chlordécone